alors le coup de coeur du cinéma les
yeux d'ali ziat cette semaine c'est un
film sorti en 1977 probablement le plus
grand film de 1977 et non c'est pas star
wars c'est sorcerer de william friedkin
un film qui est complètement passé
inaperçu à cause justement de star wars
et qu'on vous propose de re découvrir au
cinéma les yeux d'elsa pour une
projection unique le vendredi 20 janvier
à 20h30 projection qu on accompagnera de
discussion sur le film vous expliquera
comment il est fabriqué et comment et
pourquoi il a été fabriqué c'est un film
plein d'anecdotes qui devait rassembler
steve mcqueen mastroianni ventura et qui
finalement a rassemblé roye scheider
bruno cremer est bien d'autres c'est un
film qui a eu une aventure absolument
formidable c'est un remake du salaire de
la peur de clouzot c'est une
réinterprétation dans la jungle
tropicale du mexique
du fameux film le salaire de la peur de
georges clouzot donc on sera au cinéma
les yeux d'elsa le vendredi 20 janvier à
20h30 avec sylvain ibères mon camarade
professeur au lycée mansart de saint cyr
pour vous parler de ce film
j'espère que vous serez nombreux à venir
profiter de cette projection unique
[Musique]